round three of the US and US Women's  Chess Championships here in st. Louis  after a bloody second round the  country's best players up the ante with  an incredible eight out of twelve  disciples Wesley so in Perugia no Cobian  unable to win World Championship  candidate Fabiano Khurana defeated the  youngster Geoffrey Zhang to jump into a  three-way tie for first and a share  [ __ ] ese in a crushing attack to  dominate seven-time champion arena crush  which allowed 2016 champ 95 kid Z and 15  year old wasn't in any way to keep a  lock at the top with victories in their  games the players jumped back in the  ring to duke it out with more fighting  chess round 4 action coming up next